nombreux touristes qui avaient prévu
leurs vacances dans les parcs nationaux
du québec on pousse un soupir de
soulagement lorsque la grève a été
évitée
ça nous permet aujourd'hui de parler de
l'évolution dans nos parcs d habitude
également des amateurs de plein air on
en discute avec alain grenier qui est
professeur de tourisme de nature est
également aussi à l'uqam bonjour bon
d'être là avec nous aujourd'hui lors de
ce match
monsieur bourque et oui parce qu'un
autre journaliste ans
mais oui monsieur bachand sur hbo la
grève a été évitée dans les parcs est ce
que ça aurait un impact important pour
l'industrie selon vous rapidement ou et
ben c'est important parce que là que la
grève ait été évité du moins en deux
semaines sur ma compréhension pour
accepter la proposition d'accord parce
que le tourisme de nature c'est super
important pour le développement
économique des régions alors toute grève
dans ce secteur en pleine pleine période
de vacances auraient été catastrophiques
oui d'autant plus évidemment dans les
deux semaines la construction
on va y aller avec les nouvelles
tendances auparavant on a l'impression
que les gens allaient faire du camping
sauvage on arrivait avec la tente un
petit piqué maintenant j'ai rendu
différent
oui bon on parle de plus en plus de
glamping c'est à dire du camping car ce
but qui nous soit donc s'il dit oui
c'est clairement un camping c'est ça que
les gens recherchent le confort ils
recherchent aussi le contact avec la
nature mais souvent tout ce qui reste de
ce contact c'est la petite oil parce
qu'au lieu d'être sur quoi sa toile de
plastique mettant un plancher de bois on
à l'électricité on a tous les laits les
commodités si vous voulez qu'on
cherchait à fuir d'ailleurs parce qu'on
allait faire du camping en haleine on
voulait de la nature c'est le paradoxe
est que tout à fait mais on n'est pas à
une contradiction près dans nos sociétés
et on la voit aussi
moi je serai bon là vaut aussi dans le
tourisme de nature où les gens se
retrouvent finalement ils veulent
quitter la ville quitter les angoisses
et l'oppression en quelque sorte de la
ville et se retrouve à vivre avec les
mêmes contraintes en milieu naturel ses
réfrigérateurs pourra le micro-ondes
institué il ya même des gens qui me
raconte un gestionnaire de parc
il ya une panne d'électricité dans un
terrain de camping dans un parc national
hees avait causé tout un problème alors
c'est l'anti avons recherché justement
du banc lorsque la neige
certains vous rendez compte alliant
nature pour manquer d'électricité
maintenant les amateurs de plein air
veulent davantage de services auprès de
6 à la grande tendance est effectivement
moins d'équipements de cheveux louer
directement dans les parcs
oui c'était eux qui veulent plus de
services ils ne veulent pas avoir à
refaire le travail humain donc ils vont
chercher le prêt-à-camper saison que la
tante l'installation déjà fait je pense
que dans un avenir proche et ça existe
peut-être certains endroits on en voit
déjà la nourriture on pourra faire sa
commande d'épicerie aventure comme un
album dans l'avenir et le parc en ligne
prochain le parc nous nous accusera avec
un frigidaire durs remplis selon la
diète que l'on souhaite avoir
alors les gens recherchent du confort au
niveau de l'hygiène des douches par
exemple ont vu les petites douches avec
sainte cène à 30 secondes de dos mais
les gens cherchent aussi de l' aventure
se met de plus en plus ancien dans le
décor avec les risques que cela comporte
oui évidemment avec les égos portrait on
l'a vu notamment des gens même d'avis et
dans les grands parcs américains à
guantanamo notamment qui sont tombés
directement une nouvelle façon aussi de
faire du camping vous avez parlé du
glamping les yourtes qu'on voit de plus
en plus des maisons arboricole on veut
des endroits qui sont différents on veut
se démarquer des autres
le tourisme toujours été une façon de se
démarquer donc dites moi où vous allez
dites moi comment vous voyagez josé riz
que vous êtes alors on retrouve les
mêmes tendances aussi dans le tourisme
denture au niveau l'hébergement aussi au
nouveau des pratiques saisir la
recherche des activités ont parlé du
risque parce que se balader dans un
sentier sur le terre des vaches c'est
puis tout à fait exotique pour les gens
donc il faut aller d'arbre en arbre il
faut faire des tyroliennes il faut il
faut relever des défis faut se mettre il
faut on joue à lecteurs ont joué à
indiana jones est souvent passé si on
prend des risques on met sa vie ou celle
des autres en péril on parlait tout à
l'heure des esgaulx portrait au mois
d'avril avait des jeunes demi-douzaine
de gens qui avaient perdu la vie dans
les parcs nationaux américains alors on
était mérité une demi douzaine de jeunes
de personnes vraiment vous parler des
expériences extrêmes la randonnée en
montagne escalade saucisse est en forte
hausse
alors encore une fois tous et ce par
tous ces activités qui permettent de se
démarquer mais souvent c'est qu'on n'a
pas les habilités pour le faire est
moins une question qui métriques dans
tout ça c'est pourquoi est ce que
pendant les vacances une période de
repos de détente finalement
on cherche à prendre des risques alors
on cherche encore à voir la performance
mais on cherche peut-être je sais pas
pour là encore parce qu'en fait c'est
qu'il ya peut-être une compensation pour
les risques on ne prend pas dans sa vie
tous les jours au travail on vit de plus
en plus dans des vies aseptisé à john
beck part de la société durée c'est une
société qui ne prend plus de risques
alors on pas 50 semaines de l'année au
travail dans un endroit qui complètement
aseptisés avec des ordinateurs qui
qu'ils prennent les décisions pour nous
finalement et quand on se retrouve
pendant les périodes de vacances bien on
essaie de récupérer ce temps et dessus
pour se sentir vivant fait faut souvent
se rapprocher de la mort en prenant des
risques peut-être une petite dernière ce
qu'il est toujours abordable d'accéder à
la nature ici au québec qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
le prix notamment qui est chargé le prix
est chargé c'est pas tout à fait
démocratique alors moi j'ai habité
longtemps les étudiants savent les
français je me répète j'ai habité
longtemps vie ou la bosse à fait précis
des droits de la personne gratuit
l'accès gratuit mais mieux le transport
en commun sur lequel on peut compter
pour se rendre dans les parcs nationaux
du moins fait non alors ce sont des
choix de société donc on voit ici les
gens marcher dans la rue pour
l'éducation pour la santé on voit
personnes marchaient dans le rue pour
revendiquer un droit à l'accès à la
nature la nature finalement merci
beaucoup monsieur grenier merci vous